Speaker 1: Donald Trump has cracked. He unleashed
a dangerous 60 plus post tirade on his failing
website, truth social yesterday Throat Central.
This is now. It's no longer funny. If it was ever
funny, it is absolutely no longer funny. Trump
woke up and went on a 60 post Q and non fueled
social media spree. Writes Rolling Stone. Now,
I am not going to publicize the subject matter
in detail of what Donald Trump is posting
here, but I encourage you. Just glance at
Trump's troth essential account and you will
see derangement. And I was scrolling, scrolling,
scrolling. There is no shortage of memes and
conspiracy theories here. It's just memes.
And this is a former president, folks. It's a
former president. Your enemy is not in Russia.
Trump retro thing with pictures of Democrats and
George Soros. That's a classic 81 million votes.
And I've never seen a pro-biden hat, shirt or flag
in my life. Right. This is a thing on the right.
If there aren't people sycophantic alley
wearing Biden memorabilia or paraphernalia,
he can't possibly have supporters. Well, maybe
we on the left don't see these elected officials
like pseudo deities. I've never gotten gear for
any elected official I've supported because I
have a life and I will vote for them. And then
I move on with my life and I don't get hats or
whatever the case may be. Just all, you know,
Orwell related memes. Um, just all sorts of.
And you could spend an hour scrolling and
half of these memes are. Q and unrelated
Trump posting one. It's like a photo. This one's
actually funny, but it's a little unbecoming of a
president to post a Photoshop of Biden falling
on the stairs of Air Force One with a bicycle
and a helmet on the floor of an ultra MAGA post
America First FBI Sex Tape, Conspiracy theories,
weird things about Adam Schiff with an exploding
cigar. Um, you know, you could. You could just
look redacted with Nancy Pelosi's eyebrows
covered with black bars, black censor bars.
Um, stuff about the FBI. Um, a picture of a
broken clock. It just. And it's just scrolling
and scrolling and scrolling and scrolling. This
is a very sick man, and I believe is that it is
a terrified man. Fundamentally, that's
what I believe this is. And by the way,
folks, the entire time I've been talking, I've
been scrolling through the memes. Trump won
with Trump sitting at a desk, a
meme of Trump posting $2 gasoline.
Um, we're still scrolling, scrolling, scrolling,
scrolling. Any one of these, if we had a
Democratic president posting them would be cause
for significant concern. And it is like 24 or even
a 30 hour potentially upper fueled, uh, series
of posts. And it's endless. I'm still scrolling,
folks. Still still scrolling. So, listen, I think
there's a couple of different things going on
here. I think Trump is very scared. I think Trump
at this point, the RNC has all but abandoned
him. They're no longer paying his legal fees. The
pictures came out where after all of the denials,
denials, denials that Donald Trump took documents,
there are pictures of the documents with his, you
know, very clichéd casino rugs in his apartment
or Mar a Lago suite or whatever the hell is where
he lives. And also, he is increasingly being
abandoned by more Republicans. Again, the vast
majority of the Republican Party is still behind
him, but he is increasingly being abandoned. I
think he's scared and I think he is losing it.
None of the excuses or the lies are working.
He doesn't have Bill Barr or the government at
his disposal to try to deflect. He doesn't have
Bill Barr out there writing letters that say, oh,
Mueller exonerated him, even though and that's not
actually what the Mueller report said. The guy is
unhinged and all he has left is is failing troth,
essentially. And by the way, that will probably
be underwater soon as well. So some could call
it sad to me. The sad thing is he'll probably
never really face the consequences he deserves